hola bienvenidos nuevamente en este
vídeo vamos a introducirnos al
famosísimo y bien conocido teorema de
pitágoras
este es un teorema muy divertido por sí
solo pero ya te darás cuenta mientras
aprendas más y más matemáticas que es
uno de esos es como un teorema pilar de
toda la matemática lo usas en todas
partes se usa en geometría es como de
hecho la espina dorsal de trigonometría
y también lo usas para calcular
distancias entre puntos etcétera
etcétera así que bueno es muy importante
asegurarnos de aprender bien este
teorema así que bueno iniciamos vamos
ante voy a enseñar lo que es el teorema
de pitágoras así que bueno si tenemos un
triángulo y este triángulo debe ser un
triángulo rectángulo entonces eso quiere
decir que uno de los tres ángulos debe
ser un ángulo recto y especifica acceso
a dibujando una cajita en la esquina
esto es un ángulo recto aquí está el
ángulo recto de hecho lo voy a hacer en
otro color acá esto es
este es un ángulo recto y no es un
ángulo de 90 grados y un triángulo que
tiene un ángulo recto en el llamado un
triángulo rectángulo entonces a esto se
le llama esto es un triángulo rectángulo
ahora bien con el teorema de pitágoras
si conoces tú la medida de de dos lados
de un triángulo rectángulo un triángulo
rectángulo siempre podemos saber cuánto
mide el tercer lado eso es maravilloso
entonces bueno es que realmente es
espectacular así que antes de enseñarte
cómo se hace eso te daremos otra pieza
más de terminología el lado más largo de
un triángulo rectángulo es el lado
opuesto al ángulo recto así que en este
caso hablamos de de este lado este es el
lado más largo y como tú puedes ver el
ángulo de 90 grados es el ángulo más
grande y por él se abre el lado más
largo del triángulo rectángulo así que
este es el lado más largo y ahí está
nuestra famosísima hipotenusa esta es la
hipotenusa y es bueno saber eso porque
seguiremos mencionando lo así que bueno
para que seamos buenos
rápidamente a la hipotenusa voy a
dibujar unos cuantos triángulos
rectángulos otros cuantos más entonces
digamos que yo tengo aquí un triángulo
rectángulo que se mira así aunque me
quede un poco feo así que mejor lo borro
ahí está mejor
ajá entonces aquí está su ángulo recto y
bueno
ok en este caso esta es la hipotenusa
este este es el lado más largo es el
lado opuesto al ángulo de 90 grados así
que esa es la hipotenusa y bueno sólo
para volvernos expertos en reconocer la
hipotenusa voy a hacer otro ejemplo más
digamos que aquí tengo otro triángulo y
este su ángulo recto
creo que ya eres bueno en esto así que
el ángulo se abre hacia acá y este es el
pod en uso en este caso es el lado más
largo esta es la hipotenusa en este caso
aquí está la hipotenusa y bueno una vez
que identificase la hipotenusa digamos
que tiene longitud
ahora vamos a aprender lo que nos dice
el teorema de pitágoras digamos que se
es igual a la longitud de la hipotenusa
así que llamemos a este lado c a este
otro lado de abajo este lado llamémosle
a este es a este otro lado llamémosle b
entonces bueno el teorema de pitágoras
nos dice que al cuadrado dice que uno de
los lados más cortos la longitud de uno
de los lados más cortos al cuadrado más
la longitud del otro lado al cuadrado b
al cuadrado será igual a la longitud de
la hipotenusa al cuadrado y bueno ya con
esta valiosa información hagamos un
ejemplo así te darás cuenta que no es
tan difícil como tal vez te puede
parecer digamos que yo tengo un
triángulo lo lo dibujaré lo mejor que
pueda así que este es este es el
triángulo y digamos que nos dicen buena
mira
aquí está el ángulo recto y este lado
tiene longitud lo haré en diferente
color
esta longitud es de 3 esta longitud es
de 4 aquí está 4 y ellos quieren que
averigüemos la longitud de este lado
ahora bien lo primero que quieres hacer
antes de aplicar el teorema de pitágoras
es estar seguro de tener o saber cuál es
la hipotenusa y estar seguro de saber el
lado qué lado quieres conocer o qué lado
quieres encontrar en este ejemplo
estamos resolviendo para la hipotenusa y
sabemos eso porque este lado de acá es
el lado opuesto al ángulo recto si
sabemos si observamos el teorema de
pitágoras este lado es ce y ahora bueno
ahora si estamos listos para aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras así que hagámoslo
am4 al cuadrado uno de los lados más
cortos al cuadrado más tres al cuadrado
otro el otro lado al cuadrado será igual
a este lado a este lado al cuadrado la
hipotenusa al cuadrado así que luego ya
nada más queda resolver para hacer
cuatro al cuadrado es lo mismo que
cuatro por cuatro eso es 16 así que
16 + 3 al cuadrado lo mismo que 3 por 3
entonces más 9 + 9
eso es igual a c al cuadrado igualase al
cuadrado ahora bien un 16 más 9 25
entonces 25 es igual a c al cuadrado y
luego podemos tomar la raíz cuadrada
positiva de ambos lados supongo que si
lo observamos matemáticamente puede ser
también en menos 5 pero estamos hablando
de distancias así que solamente nos
interesa la raíz positiva
tomás la raíz principal de ambos lados y
obtenemos 5 entonces 5 es igual hacer a
la longitud del lado más largo es igual
a 5 entonces se es igual a 5 así que
bueno tú podrías usar el teorema de
pitágoras y talks y tienes si tienes dos
lados de un triángulo rectángulo tú
siempre puedes averiguar cuánto mide el
tercer lado eso es lo mágico del asunto
así que hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que
nuestro triángulo se mira esta vez así
aquí está el ángulo
hasta el ángulo recto aquí ok entonces
digamos que el estrado tira longitud 12
y digamos que este lado tiene longitud 6
y queremos saber cuánto mide este lado
de acá entonces bueno como como lo acabo
de decir lo primero que queremos saber
primero primero queremos identificar la
hipotenusa y la hipotenusa será el lado
opuesto al ángulo recto entonces te
diriges hacia este lado el lado opuesto
al ángulo recto el lado más largo esa es
la hipotenusa y si pensamos en el
teorema de pitágoras al cuadrado más b
al cuadrado es igual a c al cuadrado 2
ese lado 12 lo puedes tomar como se baja
esa es la hipotenusa así que sea al
cuadrado de la hipotenusa al cuadrado
entonces se es igual a 12 y estos lados
realmente no importa qué nombre lleven
si sean veo veo a am o viceversa digamos
que a es igual a 6 y que b es igual a
signo de interrogación entonces bueno
ahora si podemos aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras
así que al cuadrado es igual a 6 al
cuadrado en 6 al cuadrado más el lado
del misterio que es b al cuadrado es
igual a la hipotenusa al cuadrado
entonces eso es igual a 12 al cuadrado y
ahora ya podemos resolver para ver
nótese que que no estoy resolviendo para
la hipotenusa esta vez estamos
resolviendo para uno de los lados más
cortos
ahora hay que recordar en el último
ejemplo estábamos resolviendo para la
hipotenusa donde la hipotenusa s
por eso es importante siempre recordar
al cuadrado más b al cuadrado es igual a
c al cuadrado donde se es la longitud de
la hipotenusa y entonces tenemos 36 más
b al cuadrado es igual a 12 al cuadrado
entonces es 144 12 x 12 144 podemos
después restar 36 de ambos lados de la
ecuación restamos 36 estos ahora estos
se van a cancelar y en el lado izquierdo
se cancelan y nos quedan b es igual b al
cuadrado es igual
a 144 36 eso es igual a 144 menos 36 114
luego resta 6 así que es igual a 108
esto será igual a 108 eso es igual a b
al cuadrado es igual a 108 y ahora
queremos tomar la raíz cuadrada positiva
de ambos lados entonces obtienes que b
es igual a raíz de 108 y veamos si
podemos simplificar esto un poco la
factorización prima de 108 para
simplificar el radical así que vamos a
hacer eso factor hicimos tenemos que 108
es lo mismo que veamos es lo mismo que
22 por 54 2 por 54 lo cual es lo mismo
que 2 por 27 y esto es lo mismo que 3
por 9 entonces tenemos que raíz de 3 lo
mismo que dos por dos
entonces esto es igual a 2 x 2 x
bueno de hecho no he terminado aquí y
esto se puede factorizar todavía 3 por 3
entonces tenemos 2 por 2 por 3 x 3 por 3
y así tenemos un par de cuadrados
perfectos lo pondré más organizado
entonces bueno esto es un ejercicio para
simplificar radicales te encontrarás
mucho con esto mientras a los ejercicios
que requieren el teorema de pitágoras
para ser resueltos y así que bueno esto
es lo mismo que la raíz la raíz de dos
por dos por tres por tres por la raíz de
este último 3 entonces esto es lo mismo
de hecho de hecho puedes hacer esto si
quieres mentalmente o en un papel o en
un papel y no mentalmente como tú
quieras
esto va que es igual 2 por 2 es 4 y 4
por 9 36 esto es la raíz de 36 por raíz
de 3 la raíz cuadrada de 36 6 entonces
tenemos 6 por raíz de 3 así que la
longitud debe aunque tú
podría simplemente dejarlo como raíz de
108 o podrías podrías decir que es igual
a 6 por raíz de 3 entonces 6 por raíz de
3 esto mide 12 esto mide 6 y esto es
bueno la raíz de 13 es 1 punto algo algo
entonces será un poco más grande que 6 y
bueno ahí lo tenemos para él